unter dem kilometer dicken eisschild der
antarktis befindet sich eine welt über
die bislang kaum etwas bekannt ist jetzt
ist es einem internationalen
forschungsteam gelungen 1000 meter
tiefes loch zu graben und dabei einen
see anzubohren der direkt unter einem
gletscher liegt ein wahnsinns
unterfangen und nicht nur das dabei
wurden mehr als unerwartete funde
gemacht wie genau die aufwändige bohrung
gelangen und ob in dem finsteren see
auch die ein oder andere unentdeckte
spezies aufgespürt werden konnte
jetzt bei klick zum science fiction hier
gibt es jeden tag spannende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts herzlich
willkommen nicht nur das weltall birgt
noch viele unentdeckte überraschung für
uns sondern auch die antarktis denn
unter dem kilometer dicken eis gibt es
zahlreiche gebiete die uns bislang noch
völlig unbekannt sind was ist dort
verborgen welche prozesse finden unter
dem antarktischen eisschildes stadt wie
sieht es dort aus und wie kann man sich
die strömung des wassers vorstellen
höchstwahrscheinlich verbergen sich in
diesen unerforschten regionen zu dem
auch organismen von denen wir bislang
nicht einmal etwas an nicht umsonst hat
die wissenschaftliche fachzeitschrift
nature
die welt unter dem ewigen eis der
antarktis einmal als das größte
unerforschte ökosystem des planeten
bezeichnet denn um in die entsprechenden
tiefen zu gelangen sind tagelange
bohrungen notwendig doch einem
internationalen forschungsteam ist jetzt
ein entscheidender erfolg gelungen der
uns hilft mehr über diese mysteriösen
gebiete unserer erde zu erfahren ende
dezember war es geschafft mehrere tage
lang hatten sich ein hochdruck und
heißwasser bohrer durch eine knapp 1100
meter dicke eisschicht gearbeitet das
forschungsteam hatte die dafür benötigte
500 tonnen schwere ausrüstung zuvor zwei
monate lang zu der abgelegenen stelle im
süden der antarktis transportiert doch
die ganze arbeit war nicht umsonst denn
bei den bohrungen 600 kilometer vom
südpol entfernt erreichte das
forschungsteam den antarktischen sub
glazialen see namens legt mercer also so
platziert heißt unter einem gletscher
er hat eine fläche von 160
quadratkilometern ins dabei doppelt so
groß wie manhattan seine tiefe wird auf
zehn bis 15 meter geschätzt und dieses
unterfangen ist ein riesiger erfolg dann
das ist überhaupt erst das zweite mal in
der geschichte der menschheit da solch
ein sozialer sei also ein see unter
einem gletscher direkt angebaut werden
konnte zwar konnten schon in den 90er
jahren per radar seen und flüsse unter
der eisschicht aufgespürt werden von
denen wohl einige seit 120 tausend
jahren von der außenwelt abgeschnitten
sind dennoch weiß man bis heute kaum
etwas über diese gebiete solche seen
entstehen wohl weil die erdkruste wärmer
ist als die eisdecke die darüber liegt
das gestein fungiert also als eine art
wärmequelle und sorgt dafür dass die
eisdecke von unten schmilzt 2013 gelang
eine bohrung eines anderen sozialen sees
der sogenannte leg willens die
untersuchungen zeigten dass trotz der
extremen bedingungen dort unten
reichlich mikrobielle 's leben möglich
ist anzeichen für höheres leben fand
sich damals aber nicht damals ja
entsprechend gespannt waren die
fachleute auch was der analyse ihrer
proben diesmal ergeben würde
und auch diesmal gelang es dem
internationalen forschungsteam mit viel
mühe durch den gebohrten schacht dem eis
eine wasserprobe zu entnehmen und
tatsächlich auch in den eisigen
gewässern des leg mercer lauern
unzählige organismen dazu david harwood
einer der beteiligten wissenschaftler
meine aufgabe in dem projekt ist es nach
fossilen überresten von kieselalgen zu
suchen die sollten aus der zeit stammen
als sich das eis zurückgezogen hatte und
das meer weit in die westantarktis
vorgedrungen war als ich im schlamm nach
diesen kieselalgen punkte entdeckte ich
daran auch die überreste eines panzers
der aussah wie von einem winzigen
krebstier das skiteam des panzers war
gealtert fleckig und dunkel
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler konnten also nicht nur
mikroben und kiesel alten aufspüren
sondern auch spuren von winzigen tieren
pilzen und pflanzen und das ist
sensationell dieser fund von
krebstierchen und bärtig in sogenannten
tabu grader überraschte das
forschungsteam allerdings selbst auch
wenn alle tiere in den bislang
analysierten proben tod waren kann es
laut angaben der fachleute
sein dass dort sich dort unten auf
lebende organismen wir finden wahnsinn
die große frage wie konnten diese
komplexe organismen in das eisig kalte
und dunkle gewässer kommen und wie
können sie dort in den bitterkalten
sehen ohne sonnenlicht überleben dazu
gibt es bisher nur vermutungen vor
mehreren millionen jahren war das eis
überlegt messer noch ein mehr damals
haben wohl die nun aufgespürten
kieselalgen in dieser region gelebt die
bärchen und krebse sind dem
forschungsteam zufolge wohl wesentlich
jünger und haben vor einigen tausend bis
zehntausend jahren in tümpeln die sich
in dem umliegenden gebirge befinden
gelebt wie sie dann genau in den see
gelangt sind dass es bisher noch unklar
denkbar sei dass die meerestiere ein
gespült worden sein als das antarktische
eis dünner war so das forschungsteam
später habe er sieht das eisschild dann
in den vereisten seen eingeschlossen
eine endgültige antwort auf dieses
rätsel könnten jedoch nur weitere
analysen im labor geben haben die behr
und krebstierchen tatsächlich kilometer
tief im dunklen eis gelebt das
autorenteam der aktuellen studie geht
jedenfalls davon aus dass das überleben
dieser organismen unter dem eis der
antarktis theoretisch möglich ist die
lebewesen könnten sich von bakterien und
sauerstoff ernährt haben der wohl in
ausreichendem maß enthalten sei die
genaue analyse und interpretation der
gesammelten proben wird wahrscheinlich
noch einige jahre dauern
doch die chancen stehen gut dass wir
dadurch lebensformen besser verstehen
können die seit jahrhunderten die sonne
nicht mehr gesehen haben auch zum
verständnis der antarktischen geschichte
wird dieses unterfangen sicherlich
beitragen und ausgeschlossen ist auch
nicht dass auch noch die ein oder andere
unentdeckte spezies aufgespürt wird die
sich seit unzähligen jahren unter der
dicken eisschicht verbirgt dazu der
wissenschaftler john prisco wir wissen
nicht was wir finden werden wir lernen
noch es ist ja schließlich das zweite
mal dass so etwas gemacht wird zudem
kann man diese biosphäre mit
potenziellen lebensräumen tief im mars
oder auf den eisbedeckten monden von
saturn und jupiter vergleichen also den
lebensräumen wo wir außerirdisches leben
vermuten oder es theoretisch existieren
könnte oder überreste davon
die erkenntnisse des wörthersees könnte
somit also auch spannende indizien dafür
liefern welche art von leben auf anderen
planeten in unserem sonnensystem
existieren können und wie man sie sucht
das erfahrt ihr bei raumzeit lockt der
zukunft im video dafür hier draufklicken
wie man außerirdische sucht die zehn
realistischen methoden also unbedingt
anklicken und natürlich abonnieren falls
das noch nicht getan habt ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran